l'aéroport qui sait qu'on croise l'étuvé
garcia alors j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur un truc
regardez bien ce qui se passe à côté de
moi vous avez des gens qui sont très
très poilu
voilà des poils du bas et des proches du
haut est de 20 sec qui n'est pas polluée
c'est beaucoup plus joli quand même
parce que là à côté on appréhende un peu
game of thrones est là c'est l'avenir
pas le leur surtout parce que tôt ou
tard ça va tomber
donc voilà bonne journée monsieur dame
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle de when you wake a
présenté les mecs 20 mai 20 pro mail 20
x et aussi deux mondes connectés bon on
va mettre un peu les mondes connectés
uniquement x de voter pas sûr que le mec
va x alors il me jour en france donc ça
pour l'instant elle est votée par contre
ce qui est sûr et les produits qui vont
arriver d'ici quelques jours
c'est les mecs 20 et les mails impôts
alors produit hyper sexy huawei a
vraiment à coeur d'aller détrôner les
deux leaders que sont apple et samsung
d'ailleurs ils ont réussi à passer un
premier il n'y a pas très longtemps
bon c'est toujours une question de temps
à quel moment ils sont premiers qui
détrône qui à quel moment en tout cas ce
qu'on voit et ce qui est super
intéressant c'est que huawei c'est
vraiment le focus pour avoir vraiment
des smartphones hyper performant avec
les meilleurs techno et surtout être au
top en terme de photos donc ça c'est un
petit peu je dirais le credo de huawei
et c'est super intéressant et c'est ce
qu'on a vu lors de cette présentation
allons malheureusement j'ai pas pu être
présent à les ventes à londres mais mais
rassurez vous quand même quelqu'un sur
place café des images pour moi merci à
mon pote guillaume d'avoir été présent
qui est aussi un confrère d'ailleurs je
vous ai mis son twitter si vous voulez
vous inscrire et juste en bas là ici
world of wings ailes merci guillaume
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est on va
partir à londres avec guillaume allez
découvrir directement c'est made by dave
impro directement sur place
ensuite on vient ici on en parle
ensemble pour savoir au final entre le
mail vins et mets et vins trop eu quel
est la grosse différence entre ces deux
produits qu'elle est un peu l'adn de
chaque produit au final quel produit
acheté
puis en train et en bus pour partir si
charles direction oui j'adore ce produit
et je le connais pas encore mais je sais
que je l'adoré je sais pas projet le
feeling j'ai un truc incroyable je dis
ça va être un bon produit que je ne
l'espère pour eux parce que bon ça c'est
un peu con se lever quand même à 5h du
mat pour voir un truc qui craint des
fusibles bons baisers de roissy charles
de gaulle
on est au terminal 3 c'est à dire c'est
un terminal très particulier qu'on a
loué pour nous c'est à dire qu'on
voulait un endroit où on est le voir
s'exprimer correctement et pouvoir dans
le foot un petit peu la zone donc c'est
le troisième tronçon de 2 tours monde e1
le main et circulaires des années 70
donc de ma naissance
donc c'était un peu compliqué tandis que
là on a la place la moquette et 9 on
peut faire des bêtises comme ça s'amuser
donc c'était un très très bon blog déjà
et je suis content de tresques et barbu
qui parlent pas revoir
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup beaucoup ni dans la salle
de conférence pour les journalistes
on va être 2000 quelque chose comme ça
donc cette étude
[Musique]
il ya des différences entre le mail vins
et mets et vins pro ça vous allez vous
en doutez je pense que l'agent fonds
dépend sont grandes ouvertes
je vais essayer de vous expliquer un
petit peu quels sont les vrais gros
points de différence pour qu'on puisse y
retrouver assez facilement et au final
savoir qu'elle gérerait de faire tomber
mon smartphone pendant 2 ou pas ok
savoir quels produits achetés entre le
maître 20 il met 20 pro que c'est quand
même 200 euros d'écart entre les deux ce
cas c'est rigolo parce que d'ailleurs
même au niveau du prix il nous avait
annoncé un prix à plus de 1000 euros
pour le mettre 20 pro et lorsque vous le
regardez sur les différents sites de
vente en france il est à 999 euros
je pense que la barre psychologique des
1000 euros ne veut pas être franchies
peut-être de la part du web
allez savoir toujours est il que c'est
mais demain et melgven pros ont une
vraie vraie vraie vraie grande
différence mais justement quel
smartphone reste encore les deux
suspects voulaient tout de suite alors
déjà la grosse différence qu'on va tout
de suite c'est l'encoche au niveau du
matin vous avez une petite encoche pour
laisser passer la caméra 24 mégapixels à
l'avant tandis que sur le mec d'impro
vous avez un fighting l'octroi dé l
équivalent du fei 5/10 d'apple
donc il faut forcément une plus grande
encore parce que vous avez plus de
capteurs si vous n'aimez pas les
encoches je ne suis pas sûre de ses
smartphones sont faits pour vous si vous
acceptez les encoches assez petit de
lemaitre 20 pt pour vous si les encoches
très grande voulait tester vous êtes
allergique n'allait carrément passant le
macvin pro par contre si vous aimez bien
si vous ne craignez pas vous valait 123
parce que franchement tous les capteurs
vous avez intérieurs sont assez
intéressants notamment pour
déverrouiller donc le faith unlock 3d
pour avoir l'équivalent des animaux ji
d'apple c'est les lives emoji des petits
personnages que vous pouvez animé grâce
à la reconnaissance de votre visage vous
avez qu à une projection de 30 mille
points sans votre visage donc
normalement c'est assez sécurisé en plus
les c'est marrant que cette caméra 3
essais vous pouvez même scanner des
objets nous on fait une petite démo avec
une peluche pendant qu'ils ont scanné
ensuite cette peluche panda vous pouvez
vidéo des villes phares faire des
mouvements bon c'est du gadget mais
c'est assez marrant plus qu'à ce combat
ce qui est intéressant c'est comment
faire rentrer des objets physiques dans
la réalité augmentée pouvoir les animer
bon là c'est un paquet fait en avance
intéressant et tout ça grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle et grâce à
des stocks comme le keirin 980 mais ça
on va en parler juste après au niveau
design vous avez une petite bordure sur
l'eau et sur le bas dans les deux
modèles et l arrière vous trouvez un dos
en verre forcément pour la recharge par
induction deuxième
différence et pas des moindres c'est
l'écran sur le mail vin vous avez un
écran lcd une dalle qui ps 2244 par 1080
pixels de 6,53 pouces tandis que sur le
mail d'un prof vous avez un écran qui
est un peu plus petit 6,39 pouces par
contre c'est dû aux led 3120 par 1440
pixels et ce qui ne gâche pas le plaisir
c'est que sur le match d'impro vous à
l'écran qui est légèrement incurvé donc
une plus belle résolution sent le mec 20
pro un écran oled donc des couleurs
beaucoup plus vive beaucoup plus de
contraste des noirs infinie donc un
écran de meilleure qualité
et ça franchement c'est pas négligeable
la différence maintenant en termes de
puissance et de performances allant dans
les deux cas vous avez le dernier choc
de silicone c'est le cuir in 980 qui
succède au kirin 970 ce qui était
présenté l'année dernière alors le
peering 980 j'étais à la présentation à
l'ifa à berlin l'idée un petit peu pour
comprendre ce qui se passe cette année
sont des c'est un socle est gravé en 7
nanomètres ce qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre avec ceux qui rient 980 c'est
que le focus est mis en terme de
performance pour réussir à mieux vous
des tours et pour mieux capter les
contours de votre personne de la
personne tout cas qui va être filmée
pour optimiser la photo pour optimiser
la vidéo tout ça bien évidemment couplé
à l'intelligence artificielle en plus de
ça on va venir vraiment optimiser votre
machine en termes d'autonomie c'est à
dire utiliser la puissance de votre
machine uniquement lorsque vous en avez
vraiment besoin et le reste du temps
elle est à l'économie pour optimiser la
puissance l'organe puissance vraiment
moment où c'est vraiment très pertinent
et pouvoir avoir une meilleure autonomie
sur le mec vin vous avez 4 gigas de ram
sans modèle pro vous avez si giga de ram
je ne suis pas sûr réellement vous voyez
la différence pour un usage quotidien
pour vraiment voir la différence faut
chercher dans ses retranchements
notamment du jeu extrêmement gourmandes
et à pitre est très gourmande mais pour
un usage dirait quotidien à mon avis
vous verrez vraiment pas la différence
je vous parlait d'autonomie il ya aussi
une différence au niveau de la batterie
sans le macvin vous avez une batterie
4000 midi au point mort parce que sont
le mètre vingt propose avec la clé de
4200 milliards période
je suis pas sûr non plus que ça change
vraiment la face du monde toutes les
deux bien évidemment avec de la recharge
rapide regard touquet hyper intéressante
était présentée par
oui là dessus sur ses mails 20 mai
devant proust c'est à dire que vous avez
une recharge par induction qui se fait
directement grâce à votre téléphone
alors imaginez le cas vous avez deux
téléphones dans l'un des deux est en
rade de batterie ou nous est un petit
peu embêté il ya vous prenez celui
qu'elle la batterie vous le posez contre
celui qui a pas de batterie et ça va
alors recharger directement forcément
sera pompé sur la poitrine l'autre ça
c'est plutôt logique mais c'est assez
intéressant assez innovant que sa femme
un petit peu de faire un pied-de-nez aux
autres fabricants qui eux ne le font pas
à noter que vous avez une mémoire
extensible dans les deux cas jusqu'à 256
giga ça c'est plutôt rigolo
maintenant on rentre vraiment dans le
dur du sujet c'est à dire la partie
photo vidéo et surtout photo parce que
si vous souvenez de le paix 20 pro est
vraiment un excellent smartphone sur la
photo sur la vidéo c'est un peu moins
vrai et le m 23 vraiment rien de lui
emboîter le pas alors vous avez une
vraie grosse différence en termes de
capteurs vous avez dans les deux cas
trois capteurs photos sur le matin vous
avez un capteur principal une lentille
principale de 12 mégapixels ouverture de
f 1.8 donc lumineuse vous avez un ultra
grand-angle de 16 mégapixels à
l'ouverture de f 2.2 qui va vous servir
au site pour faire de la macro jusqu'à
2,5 cm donc pouvoir vraiment vous
approché très près d'un objet pour aller
photographier et vous avez aussi un tel
objectif de 8 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.4
mais quand on passe son procès vraiment
là où on se marre pas vous avez un
capteur principal de 40 mégapixels avec
une ouverture de f 1.8 donc extrêmement
lumineux un capteur plus large qui va
aussi vraiment servir à vous améliorer
en faible luminosité donc des photos
complètement optimisé un grand-angle qui
sert aussi pour la macro de 20
mégapixels ouverture de f 2.2 et le même
t l'objectif de 8 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f 2.4 changer de
smartphone vous avez une caméra de celle
filles de 24 mégapixels a qu'une
ouverture de f 2.0 et surtout ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant c'est la
techno qui s'appelle le super hdr alors
on a eu avec apple le smart hdr chacun a
son petit mot pour le hdr l'idée si vous
voulez c'est de prendre en même temps
des photos à différentes expositions une
photo qui va être complètement
sous-exposés une photo surexposé et tout
l'intermédiaire on superpose tout ça et
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle et
la puissance de calcul derrière on va
vous sortir une photo qui va être
complètement optimisé pour avoir un
personnage de premier plan
bien éclairé un arrière-plan bien
éclairé un ciel au top des détails au
top à une image quasiment parfaite grâce
à un photophone et ça c'est plutôt cool
en plus de ça derrière yann
l'intelligence artificielle qui est là
pour optimiser la partie photo vidéo et
en plus et en plus
huawei nous a sorti des coques spéciale
pour pouvoir plonger vos smartphones
dans l'eau pour aller chuter les
poissons votre aquarium tout ce que vous
voulez et ça aussi c'est plutôt pas mal
pour en finir avec les différences entre
le mail mais devint trop sur le made in
france vous avez un capteur d'empreintes
digitales directement intégré à l'écran
alors me direz vous si vous avez déjà un
frisson l'octroi dé l'équivalent de
faith heidi pour les déverrouiller
quel est l'intérêt d'avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales cité sous l'écran
selon moi c'est un tour de force de la
part de huawei afin d'intégrer les
dernières techno et existantes
directement à ses smartphones vous avez
donc le choix entre un schéma un code
faith and docks 3d et votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran
donc ça laisse le choix à l'utilisateur
et dans l'absolu c'est plutôt pas mal
alors il ya un point qui me chiffonne un
peu tu sais pas ce que vous en pensez
vous j'ai vu sur la fiche technique en
tout cas que ce mail 20 pro avec la
certification ip68 et j'ai absolument
rien vu du côté du matin je serais
surpris que le mec vin ne soit pas
certifié au moins étaient 67 a priori
pas d'infos allez savoir pourquoi est ce
que wade veut vraiment pousser les gens
à aller sur le modèle pro lisant et en
plus il va dans l'eau je sais pas c'est
assez bizarre entreprend qui est assez
intéressant c'est que sur le mail main
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir à des
écouteurs jack et des écouteurs en usb
type c'est parce que les smartphones se
recharge dans les deux cas en usb type c
tandis que sur le modèle pro vous n'avez
la possibilité d'avoir que des écouteurs
en usb type c'est donc pas d'écouteurs
en jack donc pas de prix jack sur le
modèle le plus haut de gamme
c'est comme ça dans les deux cas vous
avez du bluetooth 5.0 et tourne avec la
surcouche est moyen est mu fabre fcm u9
sur un android 9 paille il ya d'autres
nouveautés avec la possibilité d'avoir
un petit dongle pour le brancher
directement en mode pc bon tout ça on
n'en parlera plus tard lors des phases
de test
il y aussi une petite différence au
niveau des couleurs sur le mec vin vous
l'avez en twilight en noir et en bleu
tandis que sur le m 23 vous l'avez
effectivement sur noir twilight et bleu
mais également en vert émeraude
oui nous aussi présenté un acte vain rs
avec un design par porsche bon on va
passer rapidement dessus parce qu'un
smartphone entre 1600 euros à 2000 euros
je suis pas sûr du fric très nombreux
allers dessus mise à part qu'il a un
beau design en cuir qu'il est rapide
qu'il est puissant tout ça forme en bref
on va se concentrer sur le made by mahi
bine proton je vous invite d'ailleurs à
vous abonner et à rester connectés parce
que on va reparler de ces smartphones on
va du moins testé un de ces deux
smartphones d'ici quelques jours
histoire de pouvoir se faire une idée un
peu plus précise sur la bête et savoir
au final ils sont vraiment intéressants
alors connaissant la qualité de huawei
et notamment au niveau des capteurs
photo je peux déjà vous dire qu'à mon
avis le mec 20 pro est une petite bombe
atomique
maintenant on va la gagner aussi du côté
de la vidéo on va être testée sous
toutes les coutures donc je vous invite
bien évidemment à vous abonner
alors la question quels produits choisir
entre le met 20 elmett23 donc je dirais
qu'il ya quand même deux cents euros
d'écart entre les deux produits
quand on arrive à les budgets à 799
euros et 999 euros 200 euros d'écart
alors 200 euros c'est beaucoup d'argent
je peux pas dire contraire mais pour 200
euros franchement franchement ça vaut le
coup de passer directement sur le mail
d'un gros capteur d'empreintes digitales
situé directement sous l'écran on peut
me dire que c'est un gadget mais croyez
moi que c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
d'autant plus que si vous prenez votre
médecin vous allez déverrouiller avec
votre mac votre code ou alors avec un
pinceau unlock mais vous aurez pas être
fait sur une loque trois dimensions dont
bon on reste un peu sur la fin mais ce
qui fait vraiment la grosse grosse
grosse différence ça va se faire au
niveau de la qualité de l'écran au
niveau de l'écran oled
vous avez une meilleure définition vous
allez avoir des images qui vont être
vraiment beaucoup plus belle et en plus
de ça la grosse énorme différence va se
faire au niveau du capteur photo 40
mégapixels pour un capteur principal
c'est juste énorme
vous avez donc avoir des images qui vont
être complètement sublimer et croyez moi
ça s'est vraiment bien après je vous
dirais que la partie autonomie bon à mon
avis ça va être un kif qui savent se
tenir dans un mouchoir de poche et pour
moi après tout le reste c'est du point
de détail 4 gigas de ram 6 giga de ram
vous disais bon pour moi c'est pareil ça
va se tenir dans un mouchoir de poche
très clairement à 200 euros près je vous
conseille vraiment d'aller 100 m 20 pro
vous a effectivement une plus grande
encore
vous allez avoir un déverrouillage
beaucoup plus sécurisée avec le fait
seul bloc 3 dimensions qu'il fait
pouvoir animer ces petits des mots
disent aussi plutôt pas mal voilà donc
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous préférez
vous personnellement
il devint un match d'impro qu'ici vous
intéresse je vous ai mis des liens bien
évidemment en bas dans la description
merci à vous merci guillaume de m'avoir
fait la gentillesse et le plaisir de
m'avoir envoyé directement des images de
londres donne rendez vous très bientôt
pour les thaïs des exclus pas mal de
choses donc on s'abonne et on reste
connectés à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]